[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
lundi 21 février voici les titres
la plateforme anti discrimination point
fr fête ses un an lancé par le défenseur
des droits en février 2021 elle permet
de lutter contre les discriminations
un dispositif supplémentaire pour faire
valoir ses droits l outil met à
disposition des écoutants juriste le
bilan un an après une maison des femmes
vient d'ouvrir ses portes dans les
yvelines la maison calypso s'adresse aux
femmes victimes de violence sur place
une dizaine de professionnels assurent
leur prise en charge leur mission
écouter et soigné découverte de la
structure dans ce journal et puis karl
olive maire de poissy a rendu son
rapport au gouvernement sur l'insertion
par le sport des jeunes des quartiers
objectif favoriser l'égalité des chances
et l'inclusion au programme 24
préconisations parmi lesquelles la
création de thierry lieux sportifs ou
encore les travaux d'intérêt général par
le sport
[Musique]
et le défenseur des droits c'est une
autorité administrative indépendante de
l'état l'objectif c'est lutter contre
les discriminations faire valoir les
droits de chacun et promouvoir l'égalité
depuis un peu plus d'un an un nouveau
dispositif est proposé pour lutter
contre ces discriminations et c'est la
plate forme justement
anti-discrimination point fr elle permet
à tout public et de joindre un écoutant
juristes et justement c'est un outil
donc accessible gratuitement en ligne ou
par téléphone au 39 28 après un an
d'existence ont fait le point sur ce
dispositif avec vos amis bouffard vous
êtes donc chef du pôle défenseur des
droits est quel bilan vous faites de
cette première année ce que vous avez
des chiffres aussi à nous donner par
rapport aux yvelines au département tout
à fait avec lui c'est avant tout un
bilan très positif c'est vrai comme vous
l'avez indiqué on a en fait maintenant
les un an de cette plate forme anti
discrimination pour l'afer qui a été
voulu par le président de la république
et la ministre en charge de l'égalité
hommes femmes et de l'égalité des
chances aussi de la diversité
la plateforme discrimination c'est
vraiment à la disposition de tout un
chacun
une dizaine de juristes cette juriste
qui sont à l'écouté de la population qui
peuvent soit par le biais d'un entretien
téléphonique ou par le biais de réponses
au chat donner des réponses aux
situations aux réclamants qui c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle en tout cas
les yvelinois les événements expériences
qui peuvent être amenés à nous saisir le
bilan après une année c'est cent mille
trois cents appels
on est vraiment aussi sur
11000 sollicitations l'idée c'est
vraiment de d'inclure aussi dans les
appels téléphoniques les premiers appels
que tout ce qui va être communication
via le chat pour pouvoir être accessible
à tout à chacun et au niveau des
yvelines ça représente environ 3% de ces
sollicitations sens large concrètement
153 appel on a un profil qui correspond
à un petit peu au national c'est souvent
majoritairement une femme qui va être
amené à nous appeler elle va avoir entre
25 et 34 ans et elle va notamment faire
étape pour en grande partie concentrée
discrimination de discrimination liée
éventuellement aux origines dans l'accès
à l'emploi
voilà pour vous donner un petit schéma
type de la réclamante chez dans les
yvelines qui a saisi la plateforme
discrimination justement ça on reviendra
dans quelques instants aussi à serait un
peu les critères les types
malheureusement calé constat qui
engendrait à la création de cette
plate-forme finalement bah en fait rendu
compte en tant qu autorité chargée de la
lutte contre les discriminations depuis
plusieurs années avait les nerfs en 2011
le défenseur des droits que
malgré le fait qu effectivement certains
dispositifs existaient il y avait
vraiment une partie de la population
notamment jeunes qui avaient tendance
tout en indiquant qu'elle se sentait
victime de discrimination un
observatoire qui nous a amenés à nous
rendre compte que environ deux tiers des
personnes estiment être victimes de
discriminations entre 18 et 34 ans bah
elles ne sont plus que quatre sur dix a
essayé d'utiliser un outil pour réparer
cet état de fait donc l'idée c'est
vraiment d'offrir
avant tout d'en découdre honnêtement
parce que vraiment on pense que c'est
important aujourd'hui de pouvoir prendre
la parole du site soigne à l'écouté et
lui expliquer si oui ou non c'est une
discrimination et l'orienter et puis
aussi lui donner les outils juridiques
pour lui permettre d'être restaurée dans
ses droits parce que force est de
constater qu'avec en fait ça abîme de
plus en plus les personnes quand on a
malheureusement un parcours qui peut
être une première discrimination il
désire notamment les personnes en
situation de handicap par exemple ou
liées à l'origine l'idée c'est vraiment
un peu de restaurer un petit peu bas une
forme de sa partie sud de la démocratie
en fait de pouvoir accéder à ses droits
quand on voit qu'on est qu'on peut être
atteint dans l'axé à ce nombre n'était
pas y avoir un impact aussi à derrière à
plus long terme bbb tout à fait on on
voit aussi c'est qu'effectivement ça
peut vraiment entre guillemets abîmé la
personne porter atteinte à sa dignité
la mettre en marge par exemple de
l'emploi durablement la mener aussi a
effectivement avoir des difficultés bas
de l'ordre de la déprime sommes
abandonnés ne pas pouvoir accéder à un
emploi pas pouvoir accéder à un logement
voilà on peut tout à tout à chacun
imaginer ce que ça peu ce qu'est ce que
ça peut engendrer au quotidien en fait
est finalement là vous disais justement
il ya des personnes qui se sentent
victimes de discrimination et finalement
ne peuvent pas le pad de faire un
recours justement l'objectif de ce que
vous disiez c'est qu'ils aient plus de
recours derrière finalement vu tout à
fait le premier outil c'est vraiment la
prise en compte de la parole des
personnes les écouter leur donner
l'information est ce que c'est une
discrimination pas on y reviendra après
sur la définition de ce que je pense que
c'est important et ensuite pouvoir leur
dire bah voilà ce que vous pouvez faire
et voilà nous nous ce qu'on peut faire
ou tant qu'autorité indépendante
impartiale et confidentiel pour les
accompagner donc ça va aussi bien du
règlement amiable on verra également que
pouvoir présenter des observations
d'appel ça devant un juge qui a été
saisi par la personne qui s'estime
victime de discriminations et donc la
concrètement la plateforme c'est pour
aussi accompagner mais sensibiliser
aussi et donc il ya des vidéos des
témoignages concrètement comment ça
marche et à qui s'adresse cette
plateforme alors s'adresse vraiment à
vous moi tout à chacun quand on s'estime
victime de discriminations par le biais
du cha de l'appel téléphonique on a
aussi un accès aux sourds et
malentendants
l'idée c'est effectivement de pouvoir
exaucer ses situations d'antan un joli
tu vas vous écouter prendre le temps
d'analyser votre situation et de vous
dire si oui ou non viables et hino
discrimination fille si vous ne l'êtes
pas de vous orienter par exemple que des
face à peut être compliqué de distinguer
ce qui va être l'ordre des propos
haineux par exemple d'une discrimination
donc l'idée c'est vraiment à ce moment
là la personne elle reste mettre entre
guillemets du parcours de sa parole on
lui propose toutes les alternatives
possibles soit on peut je vous prendra
quatre contrats par exemple une personne
qui s'estime victime de discriminations
elle a cherché à avoir un logement et on
lui a dit non c'est pas possible on ne
loue pas ouvert célibataires par exemple
avec enfants bah là on peut concrètement
appelé le propriétaire faire le point
avec lui ai rappelé lui rappeler le
cadre juridique c'est une discrimination
que de refuser l'accès pour ce critère
là à cette famille vers la scène
discrimination dont on lui rappelle le
cadre légal et on lui explique madame
peut éventuellement par exemple porter
plainte voilà devant les juridictions et
et nous on pourra aussi faire des
observations ont regardé l'entretien
qu'on a pu avoir avec la personne est
tout à l'heure on parlait aussi un peu
des discriminations qui ressorte le plus
c'est cher que dire vous parliez de
l'origine des discriminations liées à
l'origine y oscille l'emploi
quels sont les autres par exemple qui
ressortent le plus alors wagon vraiment
une discrimination ça me paraît
important de le rappeler c'est vraiment
un traitement défavorable différencier
entre deux personnes qui sont placés
dans une situation comparable en raison
d'un critère donc là le critère comme
vous l'avez cité ça peut être l'origine
ça peut être la religion ça peut être le
sexe le genre l'orientation sexuelle
dans l'accès est un droit donc ça peut
être effectif dans l'accès à un emploi
ou l'accès indien donc le critère qui
est vraiment essayé c'est une bonne
chose parce qu'on l'a aussi créé pour ça
le critère qui est vraiment assez
présents à l'heure actuelle c'est le
critère de l'origine c'était la volonté
effectivement quand on l'a créée il ya
un an et là on a pu voir qu'il y avait
plus 25% de saisine lié au critère de
l'origine donc voilà pour le critère
ensuite vous avez là la situation de
handicap c'est quelque chose qu'on
connaît déjà depuis plusieurs années qu
effectivement c'est un truc terre assez
présent et le troisième dans les
yvelines particulièrement parce que on
est sur l'état de grossesse donc c'est
un peu lié oui oui enfin
particulièrement tendue par cuba on sait
qu'on est à 8,4 pour cent de ses
saisines qui concerne état de grossesse
alors qu'au niveau national on est
plutôt à 4% donc voilà ça peu après ça a
croisé avec le taux de féminisation dans
le département il ya des choses à
croiser forcément et variés souvent le
territoire en fait oui oui complètement
cessé lorsque on peut voir c'est
qu'effectivement forcément tout ce qui
va être l'île de france il ya vraiment
une typologie assez assez semblable ce
que c'est très urbain ces très jeunes
aussi dans forcément il ya des choses
qui qui ressorte mais avec le temps et
l'affinage de nos statistiques on pourra
avoir des éléments un peu plus un peu
plus pro dont je pensais à vous proposer
on sera ravi de vous lire et commenter
ces notes et merci donc donc on parlait
des sortes de discriminations il ya
yvelinoise qui a été victime fin et
s'estime victime d'une discrimination
par rapport à l'emploi on va voir son
témoignage c'est isabelle jean est la
saisie donc la plate forme après un
entretien à d'embauché nous partage son
expérience et le reportage de mélanie
poker et bixente malien senti tebbane
présélectionnés par un magasin d'une
chaîne de grande distribution isabel
dréan est convoqué pour un rendez vous
avec le directeur elle a alors 49 ans
est en recherche d'emploi depuis une
année un entretien classique et arrive
la question
ou questions auxquelles je ne
m'attendais pas mon âge je
volontairement je ne marque plus mon âge
sur mon cv parce que je sais que ça
pouvait créer des discriminations il
s'était dit jours avant mon anniversaire
et je lui annonce que je vais avoir 40 9
en est là ce son visage se ferme et il
m'a dit
c'est un blocage on n'embauche pas les
personnes âgées et les yeux et vous êtes
trop clair l'entretien se conclut sur
cette phrase isabel dréan et d'abord
stupéfaite fait quelques mètres en
voiture et se met à pleurer on se
sentant humilié un hasard fait qu'une
annonce de la plate forme anti
discrimination passe à la radio elle la
contacter pour elle mais aussi pour les
autres ce que j'attendais c'était
d'abord une oreille pour écouter
c'est un service de l'état de donc je
sais que eux ils ont les arguments pour
contrôler pour
faire cesser c'est ce genre de choses
convoqué est épinglé le cas échéant tes
mauvaises pratiques est ce ce que
j'attendais c'est que ils fassent
remonter l'information
ou plus haut de cette chaîne en a appris
un échange avec isabel dréan le
défenseur des droit adresse un courrier
qu'a rappel à la loi ce qu'elle vit
comme une victoire elle travaille
aujourd'hui dans une entreprise du monde
aéronautique
donc là dans le cas présent donc la
libye noise a fait appel à un défenseur
des droits un c'est ça tout à fait ce
que nous avons ici en complément
effectivement et préexistant à la
plateforme des délégués sur tout le
territoire français particulièrement
dans les yvelines en a dix qui sont
présents dans une quinzaine de lieux
donc aussi bien des lieux type maison de
justice et du droit ccas commune
préfecture donc c'est vraiment des lieux
des couteaux si direct de du de
citoyenne qui peuvent et de citoyens qui
peuvent un moment donné faire état de
leur situation et être écouté et être
aidés dans leurs démarches visant à
réduire leurs atteintes aux droits plus
largement pas juste la discrimination
est donc la plateforme arm ou lisez tout
à l'heure c'est cette juriste qui vous
écoute
là on l'a vu pour pour la personne donc
dans le reportage finalement il ya eu un
simple rappel à la loi entre guillemets
c'était de la pédagogie mais parfois ça
peut aller plus loin finalement je crois
honnêtement oui souvent après c'est pas
on a quand même parce qu'on appelle le
règlement amiable donc été portée
notamment par les délégués mais pas
qu'eux qui concerne quand même 70 % de
nos orientations quand une parole arrive
on écrit donc c'est majoritairement
quand même du règlement mais
effectivement pour les 30% restants on
peut aller plus encore vu dit on peut à
un moment donné râpez à la personne
qu'elle peut déposer plainte quand c'est
une infraction qui avons elle a été
victime et qu'on peut nous au regard de
l'an iv on a pu mener parallèlement
faire des observations et les adressée
au juge pour dire bah voilà nous en tant
qu autorité administrative indépendante
à l'issue d'une enquête impartiale et
neutre qu'on est amené à titre
confidentiel on est arrivé à la
conclusion que madame est victime d'une
discrimination dans l'accès à l'emploi
en raison de son âge à charge après pour
le juge de trancher c'est lui qui décide
mais on est suivi sur plus de 80 % de
nos situations on est suivi par le juge
parce qu'il connaît notre compétence et
notre expertise en la matière donc voilà
vous avez vraiment un
un panel de possibilités aussi bien le
règlement amiable que aller en justice
pour faire est reconnu dans ses droits à
voir une condamnation et peut-être des
fois des endettés qui peuvent être
accompagnés redirigé dans tous les cas
tout à fait c'est vraiment notre notre
notre credo aussi c'est de pouvoir
accueillir est donnée à un moment donné
un outil une orientation une option à la
personne qui est venu nous voir et qui
s'estiment victimes de discrimination ou
d'atteintes plus plus largement à ses
droits alors on va on va appeler à
nouveau la plateforme assez anti
discrimination point fr il ya aussi un
numéro de téléphone le 39 28 si je ne
dis pas de bêtises voilà vers écouter
merci beaucoup fawaz amondji d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle un vous êtes chef
du pôle du défenseur des droits
[Musique]
une maison pour écouter les femmes
victimes de violences sexuelles
conjugales ou intrafamiliales la maison
à calypso vient d'ouvrir ses portes dans
les yvelines à l'est situé à plaisir et
elle dispose d'une dizaine de
professionnels sages-femmes psychologue
ou encore juriste l'objectif c'est
assurer une prise en charge
personnalisée elle découverte de cette
structure avec mathilde de franck ou
fans commencent à reculer dans la
première patiente et ils filent saveur
ouais on a comme on doit le département
des yvelines possède dorénavant sa
propre maison des femmes situé à côté du
centre hospitalier de plaisir la maison
calypso a ouvert ses portes fin janvier
sa mission écouter soigner et
accompagner toutes les femmes en
difficulté ou victimes de violences les
femmes ont une adresse c'est une bonne
nouvelle on sait que 100 femmes par an
meurent sous les coups de leur conjoint
plupart du temps
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait rond on se
bouche les oreilles en fait ferme les
yeux parce que
ce difficile de compter non nouvelle
maison on les accueille et puis on se
réjouit qu'elle faisait un lieu la
maison calypso accueille également un
centre de planification familiale pour
répondre à toutes les questions liées à
la vie amoureuse et à la sexualité où on
trouve une table gynécologique un
appareil dé qu ici on réalise des
consultations de contraception des
consultations pour un éventuel
avortement et puis
le dépistage des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles
sur place les femmes peuvent également
avoir des rendez vous avec une
assistante juridique ou une conseillère
conjugale ça sera une salle qui sera
utilisé pour des permanences on va
proposer aux femmes aussi un accueil
juridique en fait pour seront à part une
juriste qui va les renseigner sur
l'accès au droit et puis on a tissé des
liens aussi avec le commissariat de
plaisir où il ya une intervenante
sociale qui viendra une fois par semaine
informer les femmes sur le dépôt de
plainte qu'est ce que c'est que déposer
plainte à quoi ça m'engage et puis faire
du lien du coup avec le commissariat
pour que les femmes aient une démarche
qui soit un petit peu simplifié si elle
soit déposé plainte soutenue par le
département des yvelines est porté par
le centre hospitalier de versailles la
maison calypso a déjà accueilli une
vingtaine de patientes bientôt l'équipe
proposera des ateliers de danse de
théâtre ou des groupes de paroles pour
compléter la prise en charge
individuelle et amener les femmes à se
reconstruire
karl olive a vendu son rapport au
gouvernement sur l'insertion par le
sport des jeunes des quartiers une
mission donnée par les ministres de la
ville et des sports et des collectivités
territoriales
objectif favoriser l'égalité des chances
et l'inclusion au programme 24
préconisations résultat de trois mois de
rencontres sur le terrain auprès
d'acteurs sportifs locaux parmi à ses
préconisations la construction de
charlieu sportifs ou encore les travaux
d'intérêt général par le sport le maire
de poissy était l'invité de patrice et
carmouze ce vendredi dans notre émission
2022 vite à regarder la vue surtout des
préconisations qui paraissent tellement
simple on a vu les bailleurs et à ce
titre là le premier ministre a accepté
de m'inviter au comité interministériel
à la ville à grenoble qui a eu lieu il
ya deux semaines maintenant et je lui ai
présenté trois premières préconisations
qui l'a acceptée la première c'est
laitière lieu sportif c'est quoi ces les
bailleurs qui on défriche au pied
d'immeubles les espaces qui sont pas
utilisés ma typiquement on les met à
disposition d'une association est de la
ville et on les occupe en faisant du
sport quand il ya plus de 150 m² on peut
y mettre un dojo le projet de 2000 dojo
solidaire porté par la fédération
française de judo et son président
stéphane donnot miss moi je souhaite
l'élargir avec des tiers lieux sportifs
pour faire de l'art l'accession pour
permettre aux femmes et aux jeunes aux
jeunes demoiselles dans les quartiers
qui aime bien faire la boxe par exemple
de faire de la boxe éducative dans ces
espaces ça c'est le premier sujet le
deuxième sujet on a un nombre
aujourd'hui il ya 1500 quartier en
politique de la ville en france on a un
nombre de collectivités qui sont
labellisés cité éducative par nadia
emile zola ville je souhaite que l'on
puisse élargir sa aux sports sur et
éducatives via des contrats locaux de
sport et pourquoi pas créer indicatif du
score enfle exactement des sites et
éducatives olympique et enfin justement
les tiges par par le sport voilà trois
préconisations sur 24 mais on ad'autres
la généralisation par exemple de
l'ouverture des gymnases et des écoles
le soir et le week-end
parfois il n'y a pas de créneau pour les
associations faisant nous confiance
mettons en place un triangle d'or entre
la vie l'éducation nationale et les
associations et vous allez voir ya plein
de petites choses qui coûtent pas cher
qui viennent exclusivement du terrain et
qui peuvent être mises en place
concrètement dans l'est dans les deux
semaines qui viennent et puis on
continue dans le sport le club de boxe
anglaise des murs obame l'héritage
organisée ce samedi 21 février
la troisième édition de son gala de boxe
c'était au cosec pablo neruda deux
ceintures wba et est en jeu dont le
titre de championne continentale de rima
ayadi est le reportage de bixente
merrien sont esteban et céline charles
d'un côté du ring rima ayadi championne
continentale des poids légers qui
remettait sa ceinture en jeu ce soir et
de l'autre l'ukrainienne olena medvedev
aux championnes d'europe des poids
légers
[Musique]
un combat dominé par l'api siaka grima
ayadi qui se termine par une victoire
pleine de panache globalement ça s'est
bien passé j'ai senti que j'étais au
dessus techniquement et physiquement que
mon adversaire qui est championne
d'europe donc c'est déjà top je suis
fier de moi franchement je suis fier de
la prestation
après j'ai vu qu'il y avait aussi des
choses à corriger rima ayadi se classe
dans les cinq premières mondiales wb a
grâce à sa victoire elle vise maintenant
les championnats d'europe avant de
pouvoir atteindre un jour un titre
mondial au programme de ce gala cinq
combats amateurs cinq combats
professionnels et de ceinture en jeu le
public était d'ailleurs au rendez vous
pour soutenir les boxeurs lima ambroise
crise
voir tout le monde quand même à
l'égalité et on les soutient en effet on
espère qu'ils vont faire un beau coup
moi on en aurait normalement ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il fasse un bon
combat ils ont ils ont le talent pour il
n'y a pas de raison qu'ils réagissent
pas on espère passer une bonne soirée
avoir beaucoup de spectacle on vient de
loin pour donner la force allez allez on
est ensemble ali des soirées organisées
par le club dame l'héritage un club fer
de lance des yvelines tout son sens bon
on arrive à créer ce genre ce genre
d'événement et c'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une fierté en tant
que président et en tant que dirigeant
du club je suis fier de mon équipe je
suis fier de mes athlètes je suis fier
de mes frangins parce que c'est aussi
difficile à faire ce genre de plateau le
club illinois lance un appel pour
trouver des partenaires et pouvoir
renouveler ses soirées prochainement
plus d'informations sportives à suivre à
18h30 vous pouvez retrouver michael elle
met d'euros à la présentation de votre
7,8 sport et c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis très
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]